[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport c'est parti pour le sommaire de ce
à magazine en ball-trap a remporté une
précieuse victoire contre le paris saint
germain devant ses supporters résultat
qui permet aux clubs de conserver la
tête du championnat honneur régional les
détails dans ce set puis de sport tennis
la winter cup la fed cup pour les jeunes
étaient organisées ce week-end à
feucherolles les meilleures joueuses
européennes étaient présentes plus
d'informations à suivre
équitation la pépite française victor
levêque originaire des yvelines a été
retenu par la fédération française des
jeux pour intégrer la fdj factory un
dispositif qui va les accompagner dans
leur carrière sportive à haut niveau et
les jo de 2024 nous le recevrons dans
cette émission
l'actualité sportive de la semaine c'est
maintenant sur tb 78
[Musique]
on commence tout de suite par du
handball promis cette année l'équipe de
trappes a réalisé la belle opération de
ce week-end dans le championnat honneur
régional
les trappistes ont réussi à battre le
club du paris saint-germain des images
de mélanie poker montage de romain à
ostie ni trappe et j'essaie telle
affiche de cette 14e journée du
championnat honneur régional ce samedi
1er février dans une salle bouillante
chauffée par des centaines de supporters
et trappistes entre dans la partie de la
meilleure des façons prenant le large
rapidement le score à la pause 18 à 8
ans rentrent à y croire parce qu'on a
mis beaucoup d'intensité beaucoup
beaucoup de rythme
[Musique]
on a réussi à monter les balles poser
l'objet
[Musique]
les attaques ont soumis la patience on a
récité notre meilleur handball cette
première mi temps
largement pour retour des vestiaires les
trappistes reste devant me connaissent
un passage à vide après la blessure d'un
joueur de l'équipe sur ce contact 15
minutes d'interruption au total le psg
temps de revenir après ce fait de jeu
mini arrivera finalement pas score final
33 à 25 pour les trappistes dans ce
match accroché a été compliqué contre
une équipe comme du passé qu'ils étaient
fatigués équilibre etc et reste libre
était qu'à l'habitude de jeu des matches
difficiles sont d'ailleurs partis à la
semaine dernière ils étaient préparés
ils ont battu l'équipe qui était
première ex-aequo avec nous et du coup
c'était un match compliqué à aborder à
préparer et mais on a réussi quand même
à rester
régulier et consorts commencement toi au
classement trappe reste leader avec deux
points d'avancé sur val d'europe
prochain match pour les trappistes le
samedi 29 février sur le terrain de
montfermeil quatrième du classement une
victoire permettrait à trappes
d'envisager une sixième montée
consécutive en cinq ans
on joue également en nationale 3
masculine après une belle victoire la
semaine dernière les plaisirs oies sont
retombés dans leurs travers
désir s'est incliné 38 à 33 contre
villemomble ce week-end une défaite qui
ne me permet pas aux joueurs évinois de
décoller au classement et de s'éloigner
de la zone de relégation les plaisirs
oies sont toujours 8e sur 12 hameau de
basket à présent en nationale 2 féminine
le chesnay versailles s'est imposé ce
week-end sur son parquet contre
villeneuve le score 60 à 52 au
classement lui lcv 78 est toujours
deuxième du championnat en embuscade à
deux points d'escaudain prochain match
ce samedi soir sur le terrain de
geispolsheim en nationale 3 masculine
trappe s'est facilement imposé 79 à 66
sur le terrain de l'aik montivilliers
marly-le-roi enregistre sa deuxième
victoire de la saison contre barjouville
sur le score de 92 à 85 dans ce côté à
le chesnay versailles et perdu 94 à 87
face au mans saint pavin au classement
tra passe devant lui lcv 78 et se
retrouve troisième de son côté à marly
le roi est toujours bon dernier mais
revient à un point
on continue à part du tennis la winter
cup l'équivalent de la fed cup
chez les moins de 12 ans était organisée
ce vendredi à 31 janvier à ce dimanche 2
février à feucherolles aux comités ad
zibeline une première édition qui a
attiré les plus grands espoirs européens
de la discipline des images de nicolas
lhenry des pépites du tennis mondial à
feucherolles ce week-end les jeunes
joueuses sont venus participer pendant
trois jours à la winter cup les
compétitions majeures chez les moins de
12 ans organisé pour la première fois au
comité des yvelines au le niveau est
très très haut puisque on a maintenant
des jeunes filles de 12 ans et moi c'est
vraiment un niveau de jeu et au niveau
physique et au niveau technique et au
niveau tactique très très élevé au total
sept pays étaient représentés pendant la
compétition dont la france les joueuses
se sont affrontées sur le modèle de la
fête que moi je trouve ça bien parce que
c'est bien organisé et après le club est
bien
les personnes qui encouragent et c'est
un super tournoi c'est vraiment sympa ça
apporte de l'expérience avec un haut
niveau de tennis c'est vraiment sympa et
j'aime ça en plus du spectacle sur les
terrains les supporters ont pu voir une
autre star le vrai trophée de la fed cup
certains n'ont pas hésité à immortaliser
le moment on a pu prendre des petites
photos avec
donc c'est très chouette oil très sympa
la compétition a finalement été remporté
par la pologne 2-0 face à l'angleterre
la france termine 5e
le succès rencontré cette année le
comité des mines va organiser une
nouvelle winter cup au même date l'année
prochaine en football ont joué dans le
championnat de première division de
district voisin a fait un match nul
contre gargenville un partout le
chesnais s'incline contre hardricourt 3
0 maurepas s'offrent un festival
offensif contre sartrouville 6 un match
nul entre aubergenville et où ils 3
partout cariat grésillons s'offrent bois
d'arcy 3-0 enfin bailly noisy gagne
contre le pec 5 à 0
le championnat est dominé par mort pas
de vent à gargenville une information à
mercato à présent direction le nord de
l'angleterre pour jean kévin augustin le
plaisir oit a formé notamment p j'ai
rejoint le club de liszt en deuxième
division anglaise le joueur a vu son
prêt résilié par l'as monaco et sera
prêté jusqu'à la fin de la saison par le
club de l'epci qu avec qui il est sous
contrat jusqu'en 2022 à liszt libinois
retrouvera notamment à certain marcello
bielsa l'ancien entraîneur de l'om
voudrait en faire un titulaire
indiscutable
ce week-end était dédiée au sport
féminin en france une opération du
ministère des sports et du conseil
supérieur de l'audiovisuel pour plus de
visibilité et d'égalité le vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines et
la fédération française de cyclisme ont
pris part à l'événement samedi en
présence de la ministre des sports pour
lancer leur objectif vivre vélo au
féminin marylène iapichino et méline
coquet une piste 100% féminine pour
cette journée dédiée
la ministre des sports était même au
rendez-vous pour prouver
la pratique des femmes que ce soit en
compétition ou en loisir objectif
principal prendre du plaisir
arrivé à parler plus de progrès plus de
plaisir que de sacrifices au nom de la
performance c'est notre objectif au
ministère des sports
aujourd'hui c'est important de dire
qu'aussi bien la performance des femmes
que celle des hommes méritent d'être
plus médiatisé plus mise à l'antenne
[Musique]
seuls 10% de ses licenciés sont des
femmes alors la fédération française de
cyclisme s'est saisie de cette opération
pour lancer son programme vivre vélo ou
féminin faut travailler sur ses points
faibles
ça fait deux ans et demi qu'on structure
vraiment notre taux de féminisation
qu'on commence à mettre en place à
pouvoir mettre en place des actions de
fond comme celle qu'on présente
aujourd'hui et j'espère que les fruits
de la croissance est bien on va les
trouver dans les prochaines années
pour cela la fédération a mis en place
un réseau d'ambassadrices dans toute la
france chargée d'organiser des
événements et d'encourager le cyclisme
féminin
je pense que les les femmes qui n'est
pas vraiment envie de faire du vélo
peut-être manque d'encadrement
ou de motivation d'être dans un groupe
de femmes donc voilà c'est à nous
maintenant de mettre en place des choses
à travers ce beau projet pour leur
donner envie de faire du vélo avec nous
dans la vallée heureuse
toute la journée les femmes étaient
invités à s'essayer au cyclisme sur
piste pour pourquoi pas s'inscrire en
club et faire progresser les chiffres
féminin il y avait également du football
américain ce week end en championnat de
2e division à casque d'or les templiers
d'elancourt se ressaisissent les élans
courtois se sont imposés 23 13 contre
les myrmidon de savigny-le-temple au
classement ce résultat permet aux
templiers de se replacer à la troisième
place de leur poule
on va parler à des jo de 2024 avec plus
précisément à d'équitation la pépite
française victor lévesque originaire des
yvelines a été retenu par la française
des jeux pour intégrer la fdj factory un
dispositif qui va les accompagner dans
leur carrière sportive à haut niveau et
les jo de 2024 pour nous parler de ce
dispositif nous recevons sur ce plateau
victor à l'éveil qui vont soirs comme ça
alors j'imagine que vous êtes satisfait
d'avoir reçu cette distinction
bien sûr c'est une énorme fierté de
faire partie de cette team c'est la
chance de pouvoir être au contact de 27
athlètes ont été choisis objectifs parer
2024 c'est aussi un soutien financier
qui nous permet d'apporter d'appréhender
le caire sportive plus sereinement
et puis c'est aussi un accompagnement
pour le formation professionnelle et
notre conversion est ce que ça va
vraiment vous aider au quotidien c'est
évident le sport de haut niveau c'est
une vraie entreprise qu'on doit mener
pour pouvoir faire les plus beaux
concours du monde on est obligé d'avoir
une entreprise qui soient pérennes
il n'y a pas que monter à cheval que
faire des bons résultats ça joue mais
c'est important d'avoir une assurance
financière est un modèle qui tienne la
route aussi pour pouvoir perdurer dans
le temps
je pense que dans le sport de haut
niveau le plus dur c'est pas d'obtenir
des médailles bien sûr que c'est dur
mais ce qui compte cette durée vous
aider à aller aux jo de 2024
à votre avis j'espère alors c'est
forcément un soutien important
après tout ne repose pas que là dessus
la particularité de mon sport c'est
qu'on est deux il faut un cavalier qui
soit au niveau prêt au bon
avec un cheval aussi donc le chemin est
encore long par et 2024 j'y pense tous
les jours
j'organise tout autour de ça c'est un
vrai objectif y en a d'autres aussi qui
arrivent il ya tout que cette année
notamment
donc on fait tout pour s'y préparer pour
construire mais la route est encore
longue il faut avancer les et marches
les unes après les autres
est ce que ça ne vous met pas trop de
pression justement non pas du tout moi
j'estime être quelqu'un de chanceux j'ai
la chance de faire tous les jours ce qui
me passionne
ce qui me plaît trop contact des chevaux
pouvoir monter à cheval est dehors donc
j'ai la chance de pouvoir faire mon
sport et le pratique à haut niveau
après la pression on va dire que c'est
plutôt moi qui me l'a mais j'ai envie de
réussir
montréal c'est d'être champion olympique
donc c'est moi qui blâmer tout seul mais
je crois pas en avoir des sro alors
champion olympique
vous avez parlé de 1024 il ya peut-être
cette année à 2020 à tokyo également
c'est vrai on est dans une année
olympique à tokyo
j'ai un choix qui est qualifié qualifier
ça veut pas dire sélectionné il ya une
dizaine de couples français qui sont
qualifiés tout au long de la saison et
on sera observé par le staff de l'équipe
de france et puis à la fin une sélection
tombera avec trois cavaliers un
remplaçant je suis encore très jeune
c'est vrai que moi on est un sport qui
est plus un sport d'expérience après je
pense que tout reste ouvert ce qui
compte c'est les résultats
j'espère que j'aurai à cheval au mieux
de sa forme toute l'année sur tout
moment de la sélection
et puis à moi de prouver que j'ai une
place à défendre et puis on verra ce qui
arrive alors je le rappelle vous avez 21
ans et vous allez commencer le poney à
trois ans c'est vraiment ça tout à fait
j'ai vraiment poursuivi un parcours très
classique j'ai été mis très tôt sur un
poney cette passion m'a été transmise
par mon père et puis après j'ai suivi le
parcours classique j'ai fait les poney
les juniors et jeunes cavaliers
aujourd'hui je suis senior aujourd'hui
vous entraîner à la buissière écoles
exactement
j'ai mes écuries qui sont basés à la
boissière école depuis le départ voilà
une projet familial qui s'est développé
au fur et à mesure des années qui
grossit qui se développe avec toujours
en ligne de mire le sport de haut niveau
et les jeux olympiques et vous avez une
vingtaine de chevaux c'est bien ça staff
et les autres personnels sans elle subit
enseigner tout à fait l'écurie
comporte 20 box et puis à tout un staff
autour alors qu'il ya quatre personnes
qui travaillent aux écuries mais le
staff est beaucoup plus conséquent
voilà il ya énormément de monde qui
travaillent autour de moi et j'en suis
très reconnaissant puisque sans eux rien
ne serait possible
alors vous êtes également étudiant à
sciences po paris c'est à fait comment
ça se passe pas trop compliqué de
combiner les deux c'est une vraie chance
pour moi de suivre aussi ce programme ça
fait c'est ma quatrième année à sciences
po c'est un cursus qui est très adapté
sciences po paris a créé un programme
justement pour les sportifs de haut
niveau ce qui nous permet d'avoir un
aménagement qui est extrêmement adapté
au sport de haut niveau avec des
contraintes horaires qui sont très
flexibles des profs qui sont très
présents
c'était vraiment une volonté de ma part
de poursuivre mes études j'ai toujours
suivi un parcours scolaire classique
jusqu'au bac
et puis après j'avais cette volonté de
poursuivre mes études non pas en pensant
spécialement à la blessure ou pire des
cas mais plus dans l'idée de me dire
aujourd'hui dans le sport de haut niveau
on voit cloud est aussi un rachat de
l'entreprise c'est important de nous et
aussi des relations développées
d'étendre son réseau et puis je crois
aussi que ça me permet de faire un peu
autre chose c'est vrai que les chevaux
ça demande beaucoup de temps c'est ma
vie c'est ma passion mais j'aime aussi à
parler discuter avec d'autres personnes
d'autres sportifs donc je suis ce
programme et j'en suis très fier un
programme qui a débuté en 2006 et qui a
notamment permis l'émergence de teddy
riner ou yannick agnel s'est par exemple
lorsque marc gilly j'espère la force de
ce programme aussi je crois c'est que on
est plein de sportifs qui pratiquent des
sports très différent des horizons très
différents donc c'est aussi super
agréable est super sympa de pouvoir
discuter avec d'autres il ya plein de
très grands champions dans ce dans ce
cursus alors moi je suis encore très
jeune je rêve des jeux olympiques il ya
des copains de classe comme on l'a fait
un deux voire trois donc c'est un vrai
partage d'expériences super enrichissant
dernière question en 2024 vous allez
avoir 26 ans est ce qu'une médaille
olympique est possible en sachant que
nicolas touzaint avait remporté l'or en
par équipe en concours complet à athènes
en 2004 à seulement 24 ans c'est vrai
nicolas c'est un nos plus grands
cavaliers français c'est un modèle pour
moi je pense que tout est possible en
tout cas quand
on part sur un championnat quand on
passe sur des jeux olympiques je pense
que évidemment on n'a qu'une idée en
tête c'est la médaille alors après la
couleur de la médaille ça ça dépend de
plein de choses il faut une part de
chance il faut être au bon moment mais
en tout cas moi c'est sûr que quand je
me lance dans un championnat c'est pour
le gagner et avec un bon cheval
merci d'être passé sur ce plateau on
vous souhaite le meilleur pour votre
carrière et beaucoup de titres et
surtout une participation aux jo de 2024
et pourquoi pas à 2020 un mot de rugby à
présent retenez bien son nom fabien vite
ce jeune maurrassien de 19 ans est
aujourd'hui en équipe de france moins de
20 ans le sportif qui a débuté aux mines
il s'indigne a été sélectionné pour le
tournoi des six nations dans sa
catégorie
nous l'avons rencontré la semaine
dernière à marcoussis juste avant un
france angleterre
nous sommes au centre national du rugby
ici à marcoussis l'entraînement des u20
de l'équipe de france vient tout juste
de se terminer sous ce beau soleil avait
côté le barbadien à fabien vite
fabien vous êtes sélectionné dans cette
équipe de france u20
quelle est votre réaction du plaisir la
grande fierté forcément après c'est
j'espère que le début et donc du coup
c'est toujours ça donne encore plus
envie de travailler quand on avec le
groupe c'est vraiment la bonne humeur
qui est qui réunit tôt donc forcément
envie d en vidéo a expliqué justement
comment ça se passe dans ce groupe là où
on vous a vu très assidus à
l'entraînement forcément c'est le haut
niveau
ah ouais bah forcément à tous tout est
fait pour que pour qu'on puisse réussir
donc c'est aussi à nous deux mais d'une
autre c'est hors de question d'avoir des
éclats ou quoi à ce niveau-là ça
pardonne pas et puis tout toutes les
références au match qu'on en est car en
match et c'est un essai si ça peut jouer
à ça donc c'est toujours vraiment c'est
d'être très serré très assidu et tout en
restant on peut rester dans la bonne
humeur et dans la joie la bonne humeur
mais toujours très très sérieux et très
assidus quand il faut quel est votre
objectif sur ce tournoi au bon mot juif
c'est de faire le plus de matches
possibles
montrez le maire de m'améliorer ce que
c'est les sélections c'est toujours
l'occasion d'être avec les meilleurs et
c'est donc c'est l'occasion de se
montrer de donner encore plus encore
puisque canton normal donc qu'elle sort
on essaie de s'améliorer et travailler
tous les petits détails et le petit
point qui me font défaut l'objectif
c'est quoi c'est forcément de séduire le
sélectionneur
oui c'est dur oui enfin on va pas
forcément le cdur me montrer que j'en
veux et que je me replace quoi même s'il
ya du monde
une très bonne une très bonne
concurrence je veux montrer que je vous
passe quelles sont vos qualités
justement de jeu à votre avis je suis un
homme poste je suis plutôt deuxième
ligne ses coureurs pas forcément très
rapide mais assez dans la durée à ces
techniques rien vous êtes également
joueur du racing 92
comment ça se passe vous êtes dans ce
club depuis un an
un peu moins d'un an comment ça se passe
bon ça se passe très bien je suis arrivé
à cette année vraiment une très bonne
ambiance que ce soit bas en espoirs ou
même avec le groupe professionnel avec
j'ai fait quelques entraînements
donc franchement ça se passe vraiment
très bien très très bon état d'esprit et
après au niveau des résultats bat en
espoirs ça va plutôt bien puisque on est
on est deuxième on fait une bonne pub en
début de saison on comprend mais c'était
un peu plus compliqué mais là ça se
rattraper du couple au moment on va dire
à tout et tout et au mieux au club l'a
justement aux objectifs dans ce club
ça ce sont quoi bon avoir forcément les
objectifs cc2 d'arriver jusqu'aux monts
professionnels ferme installée dans
cette équipe professionnelle après
allah pour le moment c'est aussi du que
vu mon âge et vu la peur dans laquelle
je suis c'est toujours du travail
beaucoup de travail physique notamment
techniques et toujours travaillé sur les
petits points qui me pose problème comme
ici c'est toujours essayer de rectifier
ce qui va pas trouver même sur nos
points forts entre guillemets nos supers
pouvoirs qu'on peut qu'on peut dire
toujours travailler dessus et c'est de
les améliorer sans cesse sans cesse
parce que ça il faut que ça devienne
limite des automatismes et que ce
problème là dessus donc tout ce qu'on
tout ce qu'on fait c'est toujours en
s'améliorant même si on a des points on
est montré le meilleur
et bah ça ça sert à rien de le mettre de
côté et les usa c'est bon ca qui sait
jamais à qui était déjà le meilleur
justement vous avez à 19 ans est ce que
vous sentez vous avez encore une marge
de progression c'est 19 ans je sais que
bon que son poste on est plutôt long à
se développer on va dire donc forcément
à 19 ans il ya très peu de joueurs qui
sont finies pour pour la vie on va dire
le monde professionnel donc bien sûr une
marge de progression assez importante et
je fais tout pour que pour que le sont
encore plus grande et que je puisse en
améliorer sans cesse et sans cesse vous
êtes actuellement chez les u20 est-ce
que forcément dans un coin de votre tête
vous avez l'ambition d'aller un jour
chez les a forcément si on est là c'est
ce qu'ont convient de notre passion
qu'on vit notre ère et pas forcément des
cons et qu'on en prend un peu on en plus
plus plus
une fois qu'on est là qu'on est en plus
sa marque aussi là où s'entraîne
toujours l'équipe de france et c'est
forcément ça donne envie de ça peut
venir ça pousse encore plus à ça donne
envie de revenir plus souvent c'est sûr
alors vous êtes originaire du
mesnil-saint-denis vous êtes aujourd'hui
à avoir pas mais vous avez débuté au
mesnil saint denis dans ce petit club
vous êtes allé au sky rugby ensuite
comment vous identifier comment vous
vous sentez votre votre progression
depuis ses débuts bon ça s'est fait un
peu pas naturellement mais je suis parti
j'ai dû partir de demain samedi parce
que malheureusement fermé après celle à
saint quentin en yvelines
du coup ça s'est fait plutôt
naturellement et après j'ai eu la chance
d'être détectée par par des entraîneurs
de massy qui compte beaucoup parce que
c'est un peu qu'ils ont trouvé qu'ils
assument me façonner on va dire donc on
peut dire que je l'entendais une belle
et après comment ça s'est fait assez
naturellement que j'ai toujours été très
très bosseur parce que je sais que un
retard physique à combler etc j'ai
toujours eu quelques problèmes j'ai
toujours été très très compétitif
j'ai toujours détesté la défaite et
c'est quelque chose que je fuis le plus
possible et donc du coup j'ai depuis
tout petit je suis un compétiteur en
battant et j'ai envie de réussir quand
j'ai pas j'ai pas envie de m'arrêter de
de me dire que j'arrivais que c'est bon
là aujourd'hui en équipe nationale mans
devant moi c'est peut-être le meilleur
niveau pour mon âge mais ce pas c'est
pas suffisant quoi mais la question
qu'est ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter
fabien vitse pour ce tournoi qu'est-ce
que vous souhaitez pas un maximum de
matches et surtout un maximum de
victoires
on espère décrocher le titre voire le
grand chelem à la clé forcément merci
beaucoup a bien vite si on vous souhaite
une grande carrière en équipe de france
l'équipe de france u20 jouera ce
vendredi contre l'italie à aix en
provence on passe maintenant à notre
page agents bas
[Musique]
à versailles il y aura un tournoi de dix
portes ce samedi à l'hôtel de ville de
13 heures à 19 heures trois tournages se
disputeront en simultané sans quatre
joueurs vont participer à league of
legends 64 joueurs participeront à leur
stone compétitions fifa avec 62
personnes sera également organisée si
vous voulez participer vous pouvez vous
inscrire entre midi et 13 heures en
mairie on continue par un événement à
basket peut-être unique en france deux
écoles prestigieuses de classes
préparatoires aux grandes écoles sainte
geneviève appelé à ginette et auch vont
s'affronter dans un match aux couleurs
universitaire américaine pour nous
parler de cet événement qui sera
organisée ce jeudi à 20h au gymnase mont
boron nous recevons deux personnes en
plateau françois allaman organisateurs
et prospère pote capitaine de l'équipe
de sainte geneviève
bonsoir alors comment pouvez-vous nous
présenter l'historique de cet événement
ce match n'aura nouveau nom ce match
date d'une quinzaine d'années à peu près
au départ il était petit très petit
quelques élèves qui se réunissent et
d'année en année la pris de l'ampleur
une grande ampleur pour devenir
aujourd'hui je crois
pour cette nouvelle édition un véritable
show un show comparable ce qu'on
pourrait voir dans certaines écoles
américaines assez unique dans son format
dans ses modes d'organisation dans le
fait qu'ils regroupent d excellence et
probablement avec prétention nous
pourrions dire un petit oxford cambridge
et à la française voilà est-ce que c'est
un événement majeur dans l'année pour
vous honnêtement oui c'est à dire que on
sait qu'on est
on travaille beaucoup pendant l'année on
est on est assez dans notre année et
c'est vrai que dans l'année ça reste
quelque chose de marquant est quelque
chose qui qui reste un très très bon
souvenir quand on y repense un peu plus
tard et ça reste assez assez important
dans l'année est ce que les joueurs
s'entraînent beaucoup spécialement pour
cet événement en fait on est on a la
chance à gillett
on a la chance d'avoir un cadre
universitaire on en fait en fait on est
tous
on a la possibilité de s'inscrire dans
des dents des équipes et de et de jouer
en universitaire pendant l'année dans
différentes sections et donc en fait
nous depuis le début de l'année on a une
équipe de basket avec laquelle on joue
des matches tous les jeudis après-midi
en universitaire donc c'est vrai que
depuis quelques jours on s'entraîne un
peu plus mais globalement on a une
équipe depuis le début de l'année est ce
que le niveau est intéressant oui oui
oui tout à fait il est intéressant dans
la mesure où ce sont des élèves qui ce
qui était basketteur avant d'arriver et
qui veulent continuer dans le cadre de
leur classe prépa donc à allier les
études exigeantes et en même temps une
pratique de ce sport dans le cadre
universitaire ce qui est assez originale
en classes préparatoires aux grandes
écoles
voilà il y aura combien de personnes sur
cet événement beaucoup n'y personne on
parle de 1000 personnes on parle de 1000
personnes on parle de 1200 personnes on
parle de dinde
un effectif important avec des invités
prestigieux des troupe de pom pom girl
il faut en parler qui déchire leading
qui s'entraînent toute l'année pour pour
ce spectacle pour cet événement oui tout
à fait une cinquantaine côté ginette une
trentaine côté auch un show de danse par
une troupe professionnelle une équipe
d'un nouveau sport qui apparaît le stun
ball un certain nombre de surprises
je vais pas tout dévoiler mais c'est un
véritable spectacle
voilà je crois est ce que c'est un match
amical quand même un enjeu sportif
je pense que vous pouvez demander à tout
ce qui est à à la plupart des gens qui
sont là ce soir qu' il ya un paiement
d'enjeu sportif terre qu'on veut tous
repartir avec la victoire après on sait
que ça reste un gros événement avec
beaucoup de d'extra sportif mais mais on
va chercher la victoire
justement qui est le plus de victoires
pour l'instant alors c'est sainte
geneviève ses 14 victoires et une
défaite
voilà les statistiques parlent à votre
avis le résultat du match
victoire forcément pour gérer non ce
serait un peu prétentieux de dire que
c'est sûr qu'on aura la victoire mais on
a en tout cas on va s'entraîner on on va
jouer à fond pour repartir avec la
victoire
merci à tous et devait passer sur ce
plateau l'événement est réservée
seulement aux élèves en le précise quand
même on vous souhaite un bon match et
que le meilleur gagne
on termine par une dernière image de
basket ce week-end certains basketteurs
événement rendu hommage à kobe bryant
décédé le 26 janvier dernier avec sa
fille et sept autres passagers le
chesnay versailles notamment fait une
minute de silence pendant la rencontre
contre villenave en nationale 2 féminine
les cadettes évoluant en première
division régionale ont également voulu
rendre un hommage en faisant une photo
avec les numéros 24 et 8 les deux
numéros de kobe bryant aux lakers c'est
la fin de cette émission merci d'avoir
suivi très belle soirée sur tv 68
[Musique]